twin to marry twins gave birth to
genetic siblings they say they're cool
wait what you know you can rely on
People magazine for finding like
this and for that we're grateful to them
and the work that they do reach really
it's like a submission box on their
website like hey are you a freak like do
you they're literally the modern day PT
Barnum like
like how do they find they're always
like men who was chained to a well for
65 years comes out with a 19 pound
scrotum like they always find this crazy
hey are you afraid like no it's like
those signs PT Barnum in the movie he
was putting up like freaks dogs like he
was
like
that's what they do but I want to know
how do they
um gather these stories they're hunters
and gatherers